[Music]
on this Wednesday night more casualties
in Libya the growing Mass Graves and the
desperation for Aid
outrage over a stabbing spree I am white
hot angry the accused attackers violent
past and questions about why he was out
on a day pass
the federal liberals big housing promise
today is going to be uh the first time
that we've done something like this in
Canada a reality check on the
government's pledge
useless how doctors say some popular
cold and allergy meds are a waste of
money
plus providing healing hope and
compassion everything's going to be all
right the unique Camp helping kids and
families cope with grief and loss
give thanks for joining us the magnitude
of the devastation in Libya where
torrential rain caused two dams to
collapse is hard to comprehend more than
5 thousand people are now presumed dead
thousands more are still unaccounted for
in the port city of derna where a
tsunami-like rush of water carried away
buildings and people entire families are
among the missing
this satellite image shows the Heart of
the City on September 11th a day before
the deadly floods the next day entire
neighborhoods are no longer recognizable
and on the outskirts of town a once Lush
Community all but disappeared overnight
once one of Africa's most prosperous
countries Decades of lawlessness have
left Libya fragile International Aid is
arriving but with the war-torn nation
scrambling to respond many fear it's
just not fast enough Redmond Shannon
reports
a city annihilated its remaining people
bereft
a father standing over the body of his
son
an exhausted medic breaking down
unwilling to guess how many people have
died in derna
this man lists the 11 members of his
family who died calling it a disaster in
every sense of the word
the missing are presumed dead under the
rubble and mud or carried out to see
this response team from turkey with the
Grimace of tasks combing the shore for
bodies
the dead carried to mass Graves as
quickly as possible there was criminal
negligence behind what happened over the
last 72 hours this was not just a
natural disaster the alarm never went
off in fact the opposite happened and
they were told to stay indoors Libyan
Ennis says the years of political chaos
in his country are to blame for the
disaster and for hindering the response
so even those that made it out of this
for the last 72 hours are now facing the
most incredibly difficult circumstances
because of this division because of this
rivalry and because of tin put autocrats
that never want to let go of power
so made is making it to the affected
region in eastern Libya Libyan Canadians
say much more is needed and that the
country's two competing governments have
to cooperate to get it to those who are
suffering so there's a lot of
well being here in Canada and
feeling helpless
to
Aid may help survivors through the
coming days and months healing their
grief will take much longer Redmond
Shannon Global News London
in Morocco the number of people killed
in that powerful earthquake is
approaching 3 000 and the hope of
finding survivors is dwindling search
crews are digging through endless piles
of debris for any signs of life and many
of those who survived are now spending a
sixth night out in the open many roads
are inaccessible by vehicle some people
are using donkeys to move supplies to
remote Villages there's frustration over
the slow pace of the government's
response Crystal gomancing traveled to
one hard hit village where the main road
just reopened
he washed their bodies prayed for them
and oversaw their burials three children
and three adults victims of Morocco's
catastrophic earthquake
it's one of my duties to look after the
the people who are dead the Islamic way
it really is a small Village near the at
the center of the Quake it is in a
remote location high in the Atlas
Mountains and the only Road officially
reopened Tuesday locals are just now
receiving eight
sharing what it was like the night of
the earthquake through our interpreter
Kareem I think it was a lot of shaking
and then this strut was so big it was
not like that it was bigger like about
half a meter bigger and then in the
second shaking it it goes bad and a lot
of people were inside it and they were
like afraid they didn't know what to do
but look people fell in yeah exactly
people fell in but luckily they just uh
they're out before it's well closed back
up wow okay here like in many devastated
Mountain communities people are saying
the help provided has been from their
own Community or people nearby not the
government or the military
there are questions over coordination of
logistics now five days after the
earthquake bright utilitarian Intense or
springing up along the Mountainside
for those who have fled their remote
Mountain Villages and towns a military
field hospital has been set up in acne
some of the injuries are physical others
emotional regardless of the location the
suffering here is great
this teenager lost 10 family members she
cries holding a photo of her brother
when he was just a little boy a
treasured Keepsake she went digging to
recover well there are many questions
the most pressing might be how and when
people in remote Villages up in the
mountains will get permanent housing
those tents simply won't cut it when the
rain comes and the village we were up in
today doesn't have any toilet facilities
or showering facilities rebuilding is
going to be a Monumental task
Donna crystal commencing in Morocco
tonight thanks
and to help Morocco Canada's federal
government says it will match donations
to the Canadian Red Cross all donations
from September 8th to the 28th will be
matched to a maximum of three million
dollars an additional 2 million dollars
will go towards the immediate needs of
those affected
we are learning some disturbing details
about a triple stabbing in Vancouver it
happened on Sunday at a celebration in
the city's Chinatown three people were
injured and a 64 year old man is in
custody it since emerged he was on an
unescorted day pass from a forensic
psychiatric hospital and has a history
of knife attacks including the death of
his own daughter BC's Premier says he
can't fathom why the man was allowed out
as Eric Sorensen explains thousands of
day passes are given to psychiatric
patients but this case is calling into
question the process
Festival is called light up Chinatown
but the excitement turned to panic when
a man with a knife attacked I touched my
back
three people were stabbed he missed my
back and then got my hand the accused
attacker 64-year-old Blair Donnelly was
convicted of killing his daughter 17
years ago he was out on a day pass from
a forensic psychiatric hospital that's
not unheard of but there are some people
in our community that don't function
well and are a danger to the general
public and this person is one of those
people what troubles many including the
premier is that Donnelly attacked
someone else in 2009 after being
released once before I am white hot
angry that this person was released
unaccompanied into the community
to have a devastating impact on all the
hard work of all these community members
it puts the hospital in Coquitlam and
the review process in BC under intense
scrutiny we need to make sure that these
facilities have the medical resources to
keep absolutely sure that this patient
is ready for being out alone for a day
the forensic psychiatric hospital
provides more than 4 000 day passes a
year only about seven on average fail to
return psychiatric patients must be
deemed clinically ready for a day pass
especially if there's a History of
Violence they need to be careful as to
when the treatment has been successful
and when they're safe to be released and
this event is a very very big red flag
Society must balance the rights of
patients and the risk to the community
but when an attack happens it can be
devastating for this is very serious
crime why they let him go out not just
walk out and then you just scare this
someone might hit you again the premier
says there will be an independent
investigation into the decision-making
process and to ensure there aren't
others who represent a similar threat to
the community Eric Sorensen Global News
in Alberta the number of E coli cases
has gone up again there are now 310 lab
confirmed cases for comparison there are
usually just 400 cases reported across
Canada every year ten days after this
outbreak was first declared at several
Calgary daycares that share a common
kitchen Alberta Health Services says the
exact source of the infection still
hasn't been identified Heather York's
West digs into the questions parents
want answered about the public health
response
can you go
more than a week after an E coli
outbreak was declared at his daycare
Kate Maxwell's son remains at home the
four-year-old is healthy but Maxwell
says her trust in the child care
provider is gone I feel like they're
morally corrupt they don't have what it
takes to run an operation with the
vulnerable sector and I just it makes me
feel sick handing over money that I work
hard so that they can put my child at
risk Health officials strongly suspect
the source of the outbreak is a central
kitchen that's applied several daycares
in the city but after testing 11
different food samples in the kitchen
and eight samples of leftover food at
the daycares no E coli was found a class
action lawsuit against the daycare has
already been filed but this legal expert
says within Alberta there could be
larger issues at play the other big
legal issue is around how we regulate
public health we heard discussions
around reducing red tape in health care
and reducing red tape in in child care
and I think that governments need to be
cautious when they're talking about
reducing red tape because regulation is
what prevents incidents from happening
the outbreak in Calgary is now one of
the worst in the country's history in
2007 people died when E coli
contaminated the water supply in
Walkerton Ontario when it comes to food
related illness there was an eerily
similar case in 1991 among six Inuit
communities in the Northwest Territories
129 people tested positive for E coli 22
developed hemolytic uremic syndrome and
two people died a sobering reminder of
how dangerous this toxin can be as kids
in Calgary now fight for their lives
Heather your Express Global News Calgary
the Prime Minister and the federal
housing Minister have announced London
Ontario will be the first to receive
money from the government's four billion
dollar housing accelerator fund it was
promised back in 2021 as a way to help
cities cut red tape and Fast Track the
construction of more homes the Liberals
are holding their caucus retreat in
London Ontario Mackenzie gray looks into
whether this announcement is as
significant as the Liberals say it is
foreign
the new housing Minister's first major
announcement was billed as a big one
today is going to be uh the first time
that we've done something like this in
Canada and I don't want to spoil the the
news that we're going to share a little
later this uh this morning but when the
news dropped the impact seemed minor it
was 74 million dollar contribution from
the housing accelerator fund to the city
of London that's going to get more homes
built in this community
isn't new though it's just the first
time the Liberals have used their four
billion dollar housing fund that was
first proposed all the way back in 2021
the Prime Minister hopes to spend more
of it I want to challenge other Mayors
right across the country to step up with
their proposals too so we can get
building more homes but Trudeau's
challenge won't work the funds stop
taking applications from cities in
August the 74 million dollars will build
2 000 new units like this one in London
but it's a rounding error in the housing
crisis the Canadian housing and mortgage
Corporation Frazier's Own federal agency
reiterating all levels of government
need to build 3.5 million additional
homes by 2030 to restore affordability
housing starts this year are going to be
flat to downwardly project but you know
in reality we need a drastic increase in
housing Supply housing starts in order
to get to affordability
at Target the Prime Minister wouldn't
commit to no one order of government can
solve house thing on its own it takes
all of us working together one thing
Trudeau did admit house prices are too
high and they need to stall but he
wouldn't put a Time on Donna on a new
federal plan to achieve that goal
okay Mackenzie gray in London Ontario
thanks
the real concerns about Artificial
Intelligence coming up the push to
regulate the industry before it's too
late
North Korea's leader has offered
Russia's president his support in what
he calls the sacred fight against the
West Kim Jong-un and Vladimir Putin
toured a Russian space rocket facility
Putin promised to help North Korea with
its spy satellite program its two
attempts to launch spy satellites have
failed Kim told Putin North Korea would
make bilateral ties with Russia its
number one priority there are concerns
North Korea may help Putin with his war
on Ukraine by supplying Russian forces
with artillery shells and other
munitions
some of the world's biggest names in
Tech were in Washington D.C today the
U.S Senate held the first in a series of
Forums on artificial intelligence as
lawmakers struggle to figure out how to
regulate technology they barely
understand
consequences of
AI going wrong are are severe so we have
to be proactive rather than reactive
Tesla and SpaceX CE
I Mark Zuckerberg Bill Gates and chat
gpt's Sam Altman it was a crash course
on the rapid development of AI there is
rare bipartisan agreement for the need
for AI guard rails they're worried about
how it will alter job spread
misinformation and potentially develop
its own kind of intelligence some tech
Executives have said they want to be
part of shaping AI regulations though
some though have criticized the summit
for being held behind closed doors
decongestant debunked ahead why you
might want to check the ingredient list
on your cold medicine
[Music]
a nasal decongestant that's in multiple
cold medicines doesn't actually work
that's what the American Food and Drug
Administration has found and it could
result in the remedies being pulled from
store shelves new research shows the
main decongestant ingredient in versions
of DayQuil neocitrin and Mucinex is no
better than a placebo Catherine Ward on
what you need to know the next time you
shop for a decongestant
you might want to think twice when
reaching for medication to get rid of a
plugged up nose
with any of these structures a powerful
placebo effect an advisory panel to the
U.S Food and Drug Administration issued
a report saying orally administered
phenylephrine is not effective as a
nasal decongestant we've made the
recommendation to withdraw all curtained
ly available
oral formulation of phenylephrine at 10
milligram as the OTC products the drug
at the heart of the issue is
phenylephrine and basically it's a
constrictor it drives things up in the
early 2000s the main ingredient in many
cold medications was often being used to
make the street drug crystal meth some
of those medications are still available
in pharmacies they're now behind the
counter but many cold medications made
the swap to phenylephrine but the drug
might not do everything you expect it's
actually not absorbed well when we take
it by tablets or liquids so by mouth and
that's how most people take it which
means that the vast majority of people
get no efficacy but some people might
get a little bit Dr Michael reader isn't
surprised by the U.S report we've made
the same statement respect to children
but the data with adults is not very
convincing either that statement from
the Canadian Pediatric Society was
issued in 2011. if you are congested
medical experts say simple treatments
can be effective you're making sure that
you're running a humidifier keeping
yourself well hydrated taking a bit of
acetaminophen or ibuprofen for symptoms
of aching aches and pains talking with
your pharmacist is another good way to
ensure that what you take will actually
help Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
life after loss next how a unique
Retreat provides health and hope to
grieving Canadian families
there is a shortage of mental health
professionals psychologists
psychiatrists and counselors right
across this country that's left
thousands of people on waiting lists and
trying to find support wherever they can
a small charity in BC is stepping up
offering help to young people and
families navigating serious illness loss
and grief nitu garcha reports
they are my parents wedding rings
seventeen-year-old Lily Friesen wear
symbols of her parents love on her
finger my mom's ring is actually
engraved and it says everything's going
to be all right she was just seven when
an illness claimed her father's life
Lily and her mother went to this unique
camp for support for years eventually
becoming volunteer peer mentors then
last year Lily's mother also passed away
I allow myself to see memories not as
something that should be hidden because
the person is gone but something that
should be remembered and shared because
that means that the person still lives
on through those memories music therapy
is one of the tools a small BC based
charity called Lumera uses in Canada's
first bereavement Retreat for grieving
Children and Families a sort of Summer
grief Camp the first of its kind in
Canada and I think still one of the only
programs where the whole family comes
together to get support for their grief
I I don't know where I would be without
Camp Kerry after losing so many people
camp Carey uses a range of counseling
therapy dogs land-based healing and
education it's care these families
couldn't otherwise afford or find
there's one four-day camp in BC this
week and another in Ontario in October
when he was in grade one he started
acting out Crystal Blair says the camp
experience changed the trajectory for
her son when her husband passed away by
the time we got into grade two he was a
totally different kid so I think just
allowing them to be heard and allowing
him to realize I'm not the only one
lumero had a total of 145 families apply
for the two camps this year that's the
most interested scene since its
Inception in 2007 and twice as many
applicants as they have spaces during
the pandemic of the government did
provide funding for mental health
support that did not include bereavement
care with thousands of families or
across Canada struggling through grief
Amplified by the pandemic and the toxic
drug poisoning crisis Lumera is among
Advocates urging the Canadian government
to create a national bereavement
strategy like in the U.S and the UK I am
determined to help other people receive
that support because it helps me more
than I can say Lily will graduate high
school next year with hopes of studying
psychology and becoming a therapist in a
country she hopes will bolster
Government funding for grief services to
meet the rising need nitu Garcia Global
News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this Beaver chilling in
Calgary's Bow River we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]